hey francis do you need new investment
ideas no thanks i've got all my cash
tied up in venezuelan crypto ah how is
gringo coin doing it's pronounced green
gold coin my portfolio is now worth a
billion venezuelan bolivars now that's
about three quid then uh
you're right i should have got new
investment ideas well if you want to
take back control of your finances then
fortune and freedom is for you it was
founded by nigel farage who has over 40
years of experience in finance and
politics fortune and freedom is
published by south bank investment
research and is for the investor looking
to access a wide range of informed
opinions on lots of different investing
opportunities their brilliant newsletter
covers everything from causes and the
impact of inflation to the rise of
cryptocurrencies gold investing and much
more besides through their daily news
commentary and special reports fortune
and freedom can give you more confidence
in making informed decisions about what
to do with your money simply go to
fortune and freedom dot com that's
fortune and freedom dot com and sign up
for a free newsletter that will help
your money work for you the link is in
the description
i still don't think people understand
what's about to happen
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
needs very little introduction nigel
farage welcome back to trigonometry it's
good to be here and not doing it via
blooming zoom i couldn't agree with you
more it's a real pleasure so good to
have you back let's get straight into it
nigel one of the questions that i've
been meaning to ask you because as you
know francis and i were both remain
voters but very open to the democratic
argument and by the way i've been
persuaded by some of the arguments
guests have made on the show in the past
about it would you vote remain today
i doubt it i wouldn't no no i doubt it i
doubt it um i i think we've seen that
the economic disaster that happened it
is happening it's happening for other
reasons now uh
that we were promised you know we still
got sandwiches i thought we were going
to lose those yeah and look i think this
is the issue i was going to ask you
about because
the one thing that brexit hasn't
delivered which i think a lot of people
thought it would is the reduction in
immigration right and i've always been
in favor of a sensible immigration
policy as an immigrant myself i don't
see why we should have open borders or
people should be able to come without
doing the checks and all of that but
that hasn't happened nigel has it you
know despite the way that i was
portrayed for year after year after year
for even
daring
to discuss the subject
and kind of
enoch powell did the immigration
argument huge harm all the way back in
the midst of 1968 that after that moment
in time it became almost the
unacceptable subject to discuss in
british politics thatcher talked a
little bit about it but generally you
couldn't talk about it
i'd always argued
that we had a discriminatory immigration
system we were in favor of anybody
from the continent of europe and we put
barriers up to the rest of the world so
i was making the argument that we should
have a points based style system
regardless of where you came from
and that we absolutely should not
discriminate against the commonwealth
you know people with whom we have a lot
of shared history common language
you know all those things
what was really interesting
when the referendum finally came
and the referendum finally came because
of the surge in the ukip vote
and the immigration
argument or actually the impact on
people's lives of uncontrolled mass
immigration on a scale britain had never
seen
when it came to the referendum
the conservatives
and labour mps that joined vote leave
did not want to discuss this subject
didn't want to discuss it
all too difficult all too awkward not
popular at notting hill dinner parties
and in the end they realized to win the
referendum it couldn't just be us
talking about it myself and aaron banks
they had to be involved there was a
lovely cartoon when they first mentioned
australian style point system the lovely
cartoon in the telegraph and it was me
drinking a pint was quite normal but
drink drinking a pint of australian
points
sister sounds like a photograph
but it could have been and there was
boris and gov saying barman will have
the same as he's having yeah so in the
end they talked about it but never with
any sincerity and whenever boris has
been asked about immigration since the
referendum oh but it says he's
marvellous because we're getting back
control of of of who comes into britain
but never ever has he begun to hint that
it would be a reduction of numbers so
you've actually got
a conservative party who on the
immigration theme and frankly for most
of them on brexit
just embraced it for a career
opportunity never actually really
believed in it uh and numbers are not
reducing but of course it's the illegal
immigration that's leading to the anger
it's what's happening in the english
channel
and that was the story that i really
picked up on
right at the start of lockdown
and i started going out into the english
channel filming what was going on
getting roundly condemned but actually i
think i did help make that a much bigger
media issue than it is so yeah any
thought that because we voted brexit
immigration has been dealt with and it's
therefore no longer a political issue is
for the birds
so yes i'm disappointed the problem is
nigel is that people voted for this in
the expectation that immigration was
going to be lowered
it hasn't been so where do we go from
here
yeah as i say i
you know the conservative party is a
pretty vile organization um you know
they they cynically i mean you know it
took them a long time it took them to
the summer of 2019 to really
embrace the narrative but not the
delivery
i think we are at a moment with british
politics where
our levels of disenchantment
with the system and with the people
are even worse
than they were before the insurgency
that led to the referendum in the first
place um
i don't know the answer to that i
genuinely don't know i mean i think
at some point boris goes
all right
some no no
report wait for the metropolitan police
whatever it is my anger with boris
actually isn't the passes no
i mean i'm ups i mean i'm annoyed
my anger
is
the betrayal of what so many people
wanted and you've raised the immigration
question but actually that's part of
something bigger
brexit led people to believe that a new
type of politics was coming
a real hope an anticipation of a new
kind of politics we've gone back
to the old italian oxbridge ppe degree
chamocracy
of upper middle class people um
rabbiting on about net zero well if you
live in richmond in a five million pound
house net zero's absolutely marvelous
darling because we're you know we
doesn't matter to us it costs 25 grand
to put a heat pump on the side of the
house or or oh we'll have a new tesla
you know
i mean that's the kind of government
it's become so
i think what'll happen is this
boris will go
uh my sense of it is that the 5th of may
will be a disaster that's the local
elections where you know councils they
hold like wandsworth westminster are
really seriously in play
the next conservative leadership
election will be an existential battle
for the future of conservatism in this
country
you know it'll be rishi on one side
representing tax and spend big state
social democracy
i mean you know literally not
you know a ritzler paper between him and
kierstama really on the big issues of
the day
and then there'll be somebody
standing up for what i think and
understand conservatism to be
mainly you know individual
responsibility opportunity um and the
state not controlling your life and
if that battle's lost i don't know where
we go you see brexit happened because of
an insurgency
and there was a means by which that
could be expressed
breaking the first past the
post-electoral system i mean changing
anything in this country is really very
very difficult you know in fact in some
ways i look at brexit almost as a
miracle
well given the mass battalions that were
there on the side
of not even having a conversation about
it 10 years ago so we're indep we're in
a very difficult place if you could go
back to the 2019 general election
because you didn't put forward
candidates from the brexit party in a in
constituencies where conservatives were
do you think looking at the way brexit
has happened do you think that was a
mistake now nigel
that is a very good question and i'm not
saying that just to play for time
which is what they normally do yeah
i've thought a lot about that
uh i thought a lot about that
i could
have put candidates up
against all the sitting mps
i could
have gone round the country rubbishing
the deal
saying that it will split northern
ireland off from the country it's an
um economic and environmental
catastrophe for our fisheries i could
have done that i could have rubbished
the whole thing
but you know
in that particular election
2015
ukip took more labor votes than toria
votes where she helped the tories i mean
they weren't bright enough to understand
it then and
i've never been thankful but i wouldn't
expect that but in 2019 it was different
and if we had if i had gone ahead with
that
strategy
i think it would have led to 40 or 50
lib dem seats
particularly in i think frankly from
isha
through to land's end
there would have been
that would have been an orange wall
a lib dem wall
uh they thought that too that she
admitted after the election that my
decision had just pollaxed
the lib dems so what i feared
was a labor lib dem snp majority in the
house of commons taking us back into a
second referendum and goodness knows
what and and a breakdown of trust far
more serious than what we're talking
about sitting here this morning on
balance it was the right thing to do i i
i i
i am disappointed in johnson i mean not
that i've ever really believed in him
well no i mean it's not about you know
for him it's all about
rank title position it's not really
about policy it's not really about
principle but no looking back despite
everything it was still the right thing
to do and nigel you wrote an article
recently i think in telegraph about
there's a brewing revolt on the right
and i think you do say in it that you're
ready to be part of it now you're
obviously doing great work on gb news
you've got a very popular show on there
would you consider coming back and
trying to create some kind of other
insurgency and let me ask you well let
me explain why i'm asking this question
because everything you've said so far
suggests to me that okay someone like
you can come along and you can lead a
movement that will inspire people to
vote for something but at the end of the
day it's going to be one of the two
major parties delivering whatever it is
that you that you inspire and then are
going to do the thing that a lot of
people voted it's difficult for me i
mean look
number one
i did it for a hell of a long time yeah
i mean i was in the front lines
you know year after year after year
european elections no problem
proportional representation no question
what the issue was and i led parties
that won in 2014 and 2019
two national election victories leading
two different parties no one's ever done
that before but in 2015
when i put my heart and soul into a
general election campaign
and get four million votes in one seat
it's quite tough to ask me to do that
again
you know could i go round the country
you know and and really foment another
big political insurgency could i get
even more votes
than i got in 2015 probably
but what would it lead to
and for me to do that again is very very
difficult
um did it take a lot out of you
well i've given a fair bit already to
this but but
so
i think
that and you were going to mention gb
news but whether it's gb news whether
it's 3.3 million people
following on social media
whether it's things that i write for the
telegraph or
whatever it is
i still think i can
move the needle
i still think i can shift the center of
gravity of public opinion
on issues
uh i'm honorary president of reform uk
it's a bit like sort of being pushed
upstairs
and richard theis has got the energy to
go out there and do it so he's he's got
my full support i mean
i'll be honest with you every day
i get emails saying you've got to come
back you've got to come back you've got
to come back
it's not top of my bucket list having
done it for all those years
but you know what
never say never oh
well if and i've
said already to you that when boris goes
as and when that is
there is going to be this battle
is the conservative party going to
become
just a social democrat party are we
going to stick
in the osborne cameron
mold
is it going to be a party that looks
after those that already have plenty or
is it going to be that kind of
aspirational
ambitious party that wants to support
enterprise energy social advancement
uh and if it does go back to that social
democrat center and if the choice
between
you know starman and sunak let's say
in 2024 uh was negligible then i can't
rule it out it's not what i want to do
but
i'll be honest with you
you know
i enjoyed so much of what i did in
politics despite the nastiness and
there's barely a photograph of me
touring the country where i'm not having
a laugh or you know meeting people and
having fun
but
it's a pretty tough place to be
it's not an easy place to be and and
the trouble with it is
you're not responsible just for yourself
you're responsible for what the branch
chairman
of some obscure suburb of sheffield
said on twitter at quarter past two in
the morning after five glasses of red
wine
whereas what i do now
i'm directly accountable
if i make a mess of things that's down
to me so i'm enjoying life now i've
enjoyed
uh you know since the referendum of 16
i've enjoyed getting into broadcasting
something i'd never done before and i'm
enjoying that
i've enjoyed
you know not having to be
hands-on and living on the road six days
a week which i did for 20 years
literally six days a week on the road
and i'm enjoying not doing that i've
enjoyed being able after almost 20 years
out of it to get back to where i started
in financial markets
you know and and and putting together
you know as a daily email fortune and
freedom goes to 85 000 people where i'm
trying to help people not get ripped off
by the financial services industry so
but lots of things that i've done in the
last few years that means you know life
is
life is pretty cool
life is pretty good but never say never
nigel
do you think we're in political crisis
now this is a question i asked most of
our guests
and when i started asking it
i wasn't sure but i think we are what do
you think
i
trust is a very important word
as i say brexit raise the hopes
some are some were in despair over
brexit but they're quite a small they're
quite a small minority
you know and guys like you that voted
remain well now you see it differently
and that's fine
but for a lot of people
there was this sort of new dawn
that brexit was going to bring a
different kind of politics it hasn't
happened
and so yes i think it is a breakdown of
trust a belief that the system doesn't
serve us
and you know i can look right through
the whole thing i mean the house of laws
is an abomination
you know just stuff full of mates of
prime ministers and party donors the
whole thing's a disgrace
uh the electoral system
even when you get radical shifts in
general elections two-thirds of seats in
britain are safe
you know if you live in somewhere with a
massive labor majority or a massive tory
majority they're quite voting is that
we can't change anything you know an
older generation would say what about
the red wall nigel i mean that went
didn't it in the 2019 you had lots of
constraints well the red wall went years
before that
the red wall all voted ukip and the
brexit party the red wall was crumbling
in 2013
you know they were the labour voters
that were coming to me and coming to
ukip in very large numbers you know i
was the gateway drug
you know through to what happened in
2019
so yes
there are places where you can get
change but there are still vast parts of
this country where your vote makes no
difference at all where there is no
degree of proportionality in westminster
whatsoever
we have a postal voting system
uh that frankly
just leaves us wide open
to fraud abuse intimidation
in the big cities
so i mean i'm a radical about this a
genuine radical in the 18th century use
of that word you know i would like to
see complete root and branch reform of
our entire system of governance i think
brexit has got us back control of our
country it's now for us to make sure the
country is actually run properly and i
think to have a system in england
where it's just two passes
and there's no way anybody else can
break through
and even if they get close the
establishment just cheats
um yeah i think there is a crisis there
and and i
the trouble is
in the past
when people ask me questions like that
i always had an answer
as to how i thought we could break this
up and right now i haven't got that
answer well the problem you have is if
you talk about proportional
representation forget about the merits
of this just how are you going to get it
if you've got two parties that are
massively invested and keeping that's
right and that's why changing anything
is difficult i mean i mean equally you
know we don't have open primaries
you know if the labor and conservative
parties have genuine open private
shortlists now yeah we might get a very
different
kind of leadership i'll be honest with
you
even when boris goes if there were open
primaries in this country i would put my
name forward
barrage prime minister leader of
conservatives i would put my name on
yeah i can see that then you'd have a
lot of okay we're not a presidential
system i get that but yeah you know the
idea
you love me or hate me but the idea that
someone like me is completely excluded
from this
i mean the conservative party wouldn't
even have me as a member
it's a very interesting it's bizarre
it's a very it's it i mean pr does have
a lot of disadvantages i mean david
starkey who you you've spoken with as
well he made this point when we had him
on a long time ago that the one thing
about
first-past-the-post is it prevents
extremism being reflected so
um
that is a concern where you might get
you know bmp getting five percent not
not today but ten years ago whenever you
know something i don't buy that i just
don't buy that because the bnp did
achieve that they got a million votes
yeah in the european elections of 2009
the bmp did that
and once they had elected
representatives look what happened it's
very interesting that when you put a bit
of sunlight onto organizations like this
they actually they actually divide and
wither away fairly quickly
of course there has to be a threshold
you know a sensible threshold but why
shouldn't
if there's a big view in this country
why shouldn't that have a degree of
representation
and the argument against pr systems is
that it leads to weak government well
frankly germany since 1945 has pretty
much had coalitions all the way through
and for what i can see they've done
quite well
you know so i you know
first past the post worked
when it genuinely was a two-party system
but even up until 1900
we had multi-member awards
do you see it wasn't just one
mp that would represent a district it
was often two or three
and that led despite the establishment
of political parties and the whigs and
the torahs the liberals all that
but it still allowed for independence to
come through the system you know for
other parties like joe chamberlain's
party to win seats in parliament we've
got the worst of all worlds here where
it's not multi-member constituencies and
it's that rigid first-past-the-post so
so look i do understand that the link
between the man or woman and guilford
or wherever it is is quite important
um but equally if you had a degree of
proportionality in our system you get a
much broader range of debate and
arguments happening in parliament you
get much more interesting people
actually coming into politics and doing
it because they believed in causes and
not just for careers um so i think a
degree i mean i said this earlier a
degree of proportionality i'm not
calling for the whole thing
to be pr but a degree of proportionality
i think it'd be very good and as i say i
think the house of lords is completely
past itself by date that we have to have
some form of election
for the upper chamber and if that means
people get elected for eight years ten
years and just say one term
say be it
speaking of proportionality and sort of
moving on a little bit nigel we've
obviously gone through a very strange
period in the history of this country
and the world over the last couple of
years and we've seen you know i don't
think you're a big government guy
i'm not a big government guy and yet we
have seen i mean on the continent you
talk about germany and austria etc
locking unvaccinated people in their
homes fining etc but even in this
country i mean i i love this country
i've made my home here and one of the
reasons i love it is
that you're free to do what you think is
the right thing whatever whatever the
situation is and you're free to have
your opinion until recently and so on
and so forth and over the last two years
we have seen the state attempting to
interfere in in things that i just don't
think it has a role in you know uh what
have you made of the last two years the
sort of authority vaccine passports the
idea of vacation mandates all of that
horrified
by it all and
in the first 18 months of this
astonished
at the lack of pushback
you know you go do a poll and you know
664 percent degree were locked down and
20 want to go further right ah what's
going on um
do you know what in the end
actually
the
good common sense
allied to a free press have won the day
well let's remember we're sitting here
in the second week of february
mid-december
we had valence witty the brothers grim
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we had boris johnson do a sunday night
address to the nation
in which he used the word emergency four
times about omicron
all the while
we have the south africans
where this variant
had developed
telling the rest of the world unlike the
chinese but telling the rest of the
world what was coming our way
and explaining that it was much milder
that anything that had gone before and
in the end would help to build natural
immunity and might actually oddly on
balance be a good thing so mid-december
emergency lockdowns catastrophe the end
is nigh
second week of february
and restrictions about to end completely
how did that happen well it happened
because we have commentators
uh press you know free press
commentators arguing enough's enough
uh it happened because there was a back
bench rebellion
i mean the same mob
the same mob that fought theresa may
over brussels and all these things
um and the good
common sense of the british people has
come into play and that's put boris into
line
um interesting isn't it that the second
country
to follow this route is denmark
also a country that hasn't joined the
euro is deeply euroskeptic and will no
doubt leave the europe all roads lead to
berlin
well but you can't deny it you know
so
so actually
this is a good sign
the fact that we've gone in the space of
a few weeks
from looking like more lockdowns to
where we are is a very very good sign
that actually good common sense in the
end does prevail in this country
as for you know
what is happening in australia
and countries like that i just new
zealand i just can't get a handle on it
but it's not just those two it's austria
it's germany it's italy it's france
spain spain it's it's i i it's the
developer well thank god we've left the
european union
oh no i mean you know the vaccine roll
out all these things actually despicable
their behavior was despicable
stunning you know stunning um i mean the
way they behaved and you know the
guardian telling us that if we left the
european medicines agency it would prove
that brexit was a death cult but it's
all wrong
yeah look i'm very worried about this
growth of huge government but i see in
canada
as we speak it's day 13 of a protest i
generally
uh i'm pretty appalled by mob rule
uh but i don't see it as mob rule
everything indicates to me that the
truckers and their supporters are
behaving peacefully
behaving well
that the attempts by trudeau and others
to smear them
as being far-right extremists simply
aren't working and this is a really big
stand
[Music]
and rather like we we've won the battle
on the nhs
vaccine mandate and i've been banging on
about this on my show night after night
for weeks what's happening in canada
i think the pendulum is beginning
to turn back and i think it will start
to turn back in other countries um but
we've seen the tendency haven't we of
governments to use any excuse any crisis
uh to build their power um and so
you know that's the next big battle
isn't it this is a battle genuinely for
liberty for freedom for individual
choice
and i am going to stick to my theme of
the last 30 years which is
globalist structures
whether it is
the european union whether it is
the united nations whether it is
the world health organization will
always seek to expand
they seek to expand well look at nato in
the ukraine they seek to expand
geography we can have a big argument it
they seem to expand um but they seek to
expand their own powers and actually the
antidote to this
are democratically run nation states
with directly accountable politicians i
i honestly believe this all fits in to
the whole theme of my political life
nigel do not feel that with all the
lockdowns the draconian measures that
we've seen what we've actually done is
open a pandora's box so next time there
is a particularly bad flu season for
example
you know well we're going to have a few
restrictions otherwise the nhs is going
to be overwhelmed if there's a new
variant next year etc etc yeah climate
log downs
why not
i mean sadiq khan seems to be very keen
to drive every car off the roads of
london um what if the you know
particle per million parts of nitrous
oxide reaches a certain level in east
london and they decide you know no more
cars for a week or yeah no i do worry
i do worry that that president's been
set but i
i do worry about that but i still think
that this
victory
of common sense that we've achieved over
the last couple of months in the uk i
think that'll stand us in quite good
stead
i hope it'll stand us in quite good
stead
but as for
austria germany new zealand
maybe it's gone it's funny isn't it
we seem to have a younger generation not
all of them but a younger generation
many of whom
seem to think that values
matter more than freedom and liberty
and safety
and safety and the rule of law
um
i i mean
how a jury
how a jury in the
trial of the colston four
could decide that what happened wasn't
criminal damage
kind of shows you what i'm saying yeah
that that and when you when you start to
believe in these values
and these values become a substitute for
religion
you know whether it's
the fight against global warming the
fight against
racism historic wrongs it's a list as
long as your arm
and you start to believe
that your view
has a
moral superiority
over people with another view that's
when you start to throw
things like liberty freedom
justice rule of law out of the window so
these are very big challenges
going ahead and i
i think longer term
one of the big issues that we're going
to have to address
if we really do care
about the size of a state about
individual freedom
is the way young people are being
educated
uh and i think that is the real
cancer in society i mean i think that
it starts at primary school
this isn't just university this isn't
just a few sort of wacky lefty
professors this is actually right
through
the education system we seem to have
stopped
teaching critical thinking
stop teaching stop teaching people that
you know here's a potential problem here
are two approaches to it they're both
valid
and you make your mind up which of these
you think is the right way to deal with
society
um and that's kind of been replaced by
well this one's
you know
good and moral and this one's evil so
that does pose
you know a bigger a big problem in the
years to come but i'm still
i'm still confident
i'm still bullish i still i still think
common sense is there i still think
there is a there is a when push comes to
shove a silent majority who are for good
things and sensible things i still think
we have
particularly brexit an important
leadership role
that we can be an example to others in
the world so yeah i can't help it i
still come out as the eternal optimist
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
we're talking about optimism but to me
it seems we're we're in for quite a
bleak year in terms of economics in
terms of inflation if you look at the
challenges the ordinary person is facing
when it comes to heating bills
i mean that's a real worry isn't it well
let's deal with those separately
inflation
a disease of money
caused by government
all right now you get inflationary
shocks you get commodity price rises or
whatever
but you also get monetary inflation
monetary inflation is caused by
governments
it's a miracle to many of us that
inflation didn't kick in earlier because
we've seen since 2008 all sorts of
astonishing money creation
measures uh entire economies frankly
propped up by massive government
borrowing and spending and increasing in
debt
uh so i'm not in the least bit surprised
inflation's come back and it's one of
the things
you know with my newsletter we've been
calling this out every day for a year
and fascinating if you go back to this
time last year
the sheer complacency of central banks
the complacency of politicians boris in
october
was telling the house of commons
inflation is not a problem
but it's not just him they've all had it
right now they've all had it wrong
just as none of them saw the crash
coming in 2008
none of them have seen inflation coming
uh and i'm i'm pleased to say that you
know i've been there with my team
calling this predicting this all the way
through we've been talking about it for
years now so we've had people right at
the beginning of lockdown saying well
maybe we should think about how much
this is going to cost and how we're
going to pay for it and no one's
interested in that when there's a big
panic but there's a secret truth here
isn't that
inflation suits government
governments that have built up massive
debts
inflation devalues the size of those
debts
and i'm not being a conspiracy theorist
but it almost is a way out and then
central banks
can't put interest rates up enough
to dampen down inflation because we're
so blue and indebted at every level
whether it's national debt corporate
debt personal debt that if you put up
rates too much too quickly the whole
thing falls to pieces so i do think
actually inflation offers governments a
way of getting themselves out of debt
and the people that pay the price in
inflation are ordinary decent folk who
see what they work for and save for
disappearing so
you know you're now being told with the
experts don't worry your poor little
heads you know it will hit seven and a
quarter percent in the uk the inflation
rate in april but it'll fall away by the
end of the year well i'm not so sure
on the fuel bill
side of things which is just i still
don't think people understand what's
about to happen
i really don't think they understand the
first week of april when those bills hit
the mat
for their q1
gas
and electricity bills there's going to
be absolute shock and outrage number one
massive mistake the conservatives
adopted price caps can you believe it
can you believe that a conservative
government i mean why not set a price
for a loaf of bread
i miss what the marxist did in general
yeah nuts policy it never works it's
nearly always counterproductive
but it leads to a much bigger question
net zero
is in economic terms
i think the most self-destructive policy
that has ever been put forward by a
british government in the history of the
nation
that doesn't mean
that i'm against finding ways of
producing energy
that emit less co2 and cause less
environmental damage but i'm a
pragmatist you know we still burn
four and a half million tons of coal a
year in this country we have to to make
steel you know what we imported all
we're importing 50 percent of our
natural gas when we've got vast reserves
possibly as much as a trillion
pounds worth of natural gas in
lancashire and cumbria alone hey that's
half the national debt it's quite
interesting when you look at something a
lot of jobs too tens of thousands of
well-paid jobs and if you're gonna if
you're gonna use the blooming stuff
anyway
you might as well make it here the
americans
rethought their energy policy
five six years ago
and the price of natural gas in america
is half the price that it is here
we then have walked onto people's bills
incredibly
25 percent of your electricity but as
green subsidies
money that goes to rich land owners
money that goes to large foreign
companies building wind farms we've put
so much faith in wind energy or if truth
be told so much money is being made out
of wind energy by those in the elites
that we leave ourselves vulnerable at
some point of a not too distant future
to blackouts so
yes commodity prices globally have gone
up but we've left ourselves absolutely
exposed not just to world markets but
left ourselves exposed
you know nine percent of our electricity
comes from france through an
interconnector you know so i think we
should be self-sufficient in energy we
should be aiming
with areas like gas to get people's
bills down i don't think a penny piece
should go
to
massive global industries in the form of
green subsidy
so i think this
i've got a feeling actually that the
energy debate and the net zero debate
is going to be huge and boris stands up
and says isn't it marvelous
we've cut our co2 output by 44 since
1990. well if you close down
nearly all of your chemical plants your
aluminium smelters your refiners and and
you move steel steel plants from red car
to india and then and then
import the products back
you yourself may be producing less co2
but globally
the net games is even more co2s being
produced so i think we've got this
hopelessly
catastrophically wrong
and
i think it's a function
of
and by the way labor are just as bad on
this if not worse
and i think it's a function of career
politicians a function of people living
inside metropolitan bubbles in london
um prey to
the lobbying influences of some people
who are rather good uh at this and
utterly disconnected from the real world
and it's about to blow up this year it's
about a blower nigel
there is a left-wing argument which
actually i have quite a lot of sympathy
for was saying isn't thatcher partly
responsible for this for privatizing our
energy companies and actually
if the government was in charge of this
we wouldn't i mean then they'd make a
mess because they always do but we
wouldn't be in this mess privatization
works where you can create competition
i was always skeptical about privatizing
the railways see it seemed to be you
know
how could you provide a proper
competitive network within that
with energy is different actually
because different energy suppliers can
supply to your home and you can go out
and game the market and swap and change
so no
i don't have a problem at all
with that but what i have a massive
problem with is green subsidy which is
put on by government
not by
energy providers smart meters
which again
is a government directive
to energy companies which will lead to
you know peak flow pricing and goodness
knows what else
um so and what i have a massive problem
with is the very concept of price caps
which of course is actually bankrupted
as it turned out many of the smaller
providers so no i look there are limits
to privatization
there are limits to it but where you can
create genuine competition that is
better than it being state run and nigel
you you bring up energy security uh and
so i'm gonna butter you up a little bit
before we get into a big disagreement
about uh nato and ukraine and all that
because i do want to talk about
geopolitics a little bit
but i think this actually plays into
your motif more than anything else which
is
globalization it's the idea oh yeah we
can buy our electricity from this and we
can buy a steel from that and we can buy
and before you know it germany's
importing its gas from russia
and even if the west wanted to do
something there you mean you're being
held hostage yeah the just in time
supply chain
don't vote brexit
or you'll destroy the just in time
supply chain with a just-in-time supply
chain suits giant multinational global
corporations but does away with any
concept of nation
it doesn't have any concept of a common
good
for a collective group of people in that
nation and this has been very much
exposed
the german thing's incredible
utterly incredible there they were
saying brexit was funded by the russians
trump
you know is in putin's pocket it was
germany all the time
i mean they've made themselves wholly
dependent and
and that of course means that our threat
of sanctions
against putin
are completely and utterly hollow and
meaningless because he can hurt the west
far more than we can hurt him
so let's talk about geopolitics now look
i've just written a book called an
immigrant's love letter to the west and
it's mainly about why i think what we
have here is actually pretty good and we
should stop beating ourselves up about
it but part of my argument is also is
the more we focus internally the more
time we spend talking about you know
this comedian made this joke and now
we're all very upset for three days and
whatever
the more we take eye off the ball and
that's why china is expanding into the
south china sea it's getting bullish on
taiwan you see what's happened in hong
kong and russia likewise you know um
do you think
the west needs to rediscover its kind of
ability to project power around the
world because you seem concerned that
nato is expanding eastwards and all that
look look i think we've made some
massive geopolitical mistakes since 1990
you know the berlin wall had come down
and we decided that nato and the
european union would expand ever
eastwards
you know empires that are struggling for
a role continue expanding it it's a good
it's a good way i know i know you just
going to johnson and i never interrupt
the guests generally but let me just put
a small counter argument the reason nato
is expanding eastwards is because
estonia lithuania latvia and ukraine
feel terrified rightly so because only
70 years ago the soviets invaded
massacre their leads took over their
country they don't want that to happen
again it's not some bureaucrat in
brussels that's making that happen it's
those countries
survival just because they want to join
doesn't mean it's a clever geopolitical
move for us to say yes i'm saying the
motivation for expansion is not look
if i was polish yeah i would have wanted
to join nato
if i was polish i'd have
crossed my fingers and voted to join the
european union probably i get that
but let's just think let's just go back
a bit further
you know
go back over the last couple of hundred
years of the of the you know formal
existence
of nation states around the world the
concept of a buffer zone
is actually quite an intelligent concept
okay
in the case of nato
this ever eastwards expansion
is has been a deliberately provocative
move
against a russia which has always been
paranoid
you know the cold war
russia was far more scared of us than we
were of russia
and and sometimes i mean if you want to
resolve a conflict right
sometimes what you have to do
is to put yourself in the mind of the
other person
rather like solving that crossword
puzzle you've got to think you know
whoever wrote this what
what were they hinting at
so we know russia's paranoid we know
that the old traditional
you know encirclement idea invasion idea
of russia is something that motivates
them very deeply by the way i don't
doubt for a moment that putin does have
expansionist tendencies however here we
are as we sit here today
with 130 000 russian troops massed on
the border
he's making one key demand
which is that we say
that the ukraine will not join nato okay
we have anthony blink in the u.s
secretary of state boris johnson some
woman called liz trust who's become
foreign secretary god knows how but
anyway there we are and they're all
saying no no no no if the ukraine wants
to join nato they can i suggest right
now we say ukraine will not be joining
nato we do understand
the concerns in moscow about ever
eastwood expansion it has come to an end
and we now ask president putin to stand
his troops down on that border we remove
from him
his causes belie we take away from him
any possible reason
that he could have
to mount an invasion and we remember
that by not doing this earlier
we've driven putin
into the arms
of the communist chinese government how
blooming stupid can we possibly be there
is no
there is no advantage or interest to us
in ukraine joining nato if we make this
concession at this stage in the aim of
bringing peace
do you know something it might just work
nigel
what if what would you say a few years
down the line when
russia takes the rest of ukraine
which it will do well if you want us to
go to the third world war if you want
them to join nato and same british
troops that's fine i mean look look look
i i am not saying
absolutely
i have a cast iron guarantee
that i can stop
the outbreak of war in the ukraine what
i can say i've got a much brighter idea
than anybody else who was sticking to
the same formula they've had for 30
years which i believe to be a
geopolitical mistake and one of the
reasons i say this
is in 2014 we had the orange revolution
in kiev
do you remember all the people in the
square
who were part of that coup
that brought down a democratically
elected leader of the ukraine yeah
that's where you're starting to live
maybe a corrupt country yeah
he may have been a corrupt guy but he
was a democratically elected leader
brought down by people in the squares in
kiev
waving european union flags because the
european union had pumped in
pre-accession aid and it was the stated
aim that they wanted ukraine to join the
european union far from being an
organization that guarantees peace in
europe i think where we are today was
provoked in large part actually by
brussels and it's expansionist
tendencies we've made some big mistakes
here and i i made those arguments back
in 2014
to be condemned
by everybody that somehow i was putin's
puppet i'm not
i just think sometimes that concept
of buffer states is actually a brighter
thing to do
than the line that we've been pursuing
here's where i think there's a flaw in
your argument if with all possible
respect of course
well i think the flaw in the argument is
if if if what we need is a buffer zone
why and if russia is so desperate to
have a buffer between itself and nato
why is russia expanding westwards
um because because he sees an historic
coming together of the russian peoples
and all the rest of it and we have to
make it clear to him
we have historical parallels there well
let's take away from him any possible
excuse he can have any validation he can
have firstly with his own population uh
you know you know and secondly with all
the rest of us um i i think it's the
right thing so what would you like to do
so ukraine joins nato that's yours
no no i'm not i'm not necessarily
suggesting that ukraine should join nato
i think what what i see is in the
broader geopolitical that's why i
brought china into this yeah the west is
weak and it's showing weakness well we
saw that in kabul last year didn't we
right and
and the people who and you'll understand
this because you understand how the real
world works you know in in the west we
talk about you know equality and
diversity and and politic well whatever
in the real world people don't operate
on that basis they operate on land money
finance weapons
technology spy espionage right oil oil
exactly all these things
yeah exactly yeah human rights uh so
what this looks like from the outside to
me as i look at it from a non-western
perspective is the west is distracted
the west is weak and all the things that
we would always would have quite liked
to have done right if we you know if
you're china well yeah you want to
expand this way and you want to take
over hong kong anyone do this so from my
perspective it depends on what people in
the west want if you want to manage
decline of the west this is what you're
going to get i have a feeling if donald
trump was in the white house we wouldn't
see a little rocket man firing off all
these rockets i don't think china would
be quite as bellicose no about taiwan as
that that's my point no no i mean look
you know biden has been a catastrophe
um
the unilateral withdrawal from
afghanistan was a complete disaster
right and far from america is back
they've actually retreated away clearly
uh and the west is now without
leadership but that's my point nigel by
by advocating for the position you're
advocating for
that's part of the same sort of well we
just need to you know appease these
people and instead of the west coming
out and going look
we are the world's superpower we are
that we're not embarrassed about our
values our values are better than yours
right freedom democracy these are all
good things and we're we are going to
spread them around the world because
this is who we are and we are the
strongest thing if you think china and
russia if they were the dominant
hegemony in the world they wouldn't do
that you're insane no i know
i just see
that being seen to make something of a
concession right now gaining the moral
upper ground in this whole diplomatic
standoff that is currently going on over
the ukraine when as i say it's in it
it's not in our interests for them to
join anyway if he still goes to war he
still goes to war
we then be much more united against him
because we would have been seen to have
done the right thing as it is we're
carrying on with a policy that's a
mistake
nigel and we touched on biden we touched
on trump so let's just move on and turn
our eye to the united states
why do you think biden has been a
disaster number one and number two do
you think we're going to see a comeback
for trump
so biden wasn't fit to do the job anyway
and the democrats are in a you know a
real mess as a pastor why do you say
that because this is somebody who's had
a very long very distinguished political
no he doesn't know he's a very long
career
he's not had a distinguished career i
mean nobody in washington would tell you
that for a moment
um i'm not going to rehash
november the 3rd 2020. i'm not going to
rehash 100 million postal votes
the fact that the scandals involving his
son
i love how he's not rehashing it the
money is
[Laughter]
he's not mentally fit for the job
but the democrats have a huge problem
because they've got the new left they've
got their own call ballistas it's very
very difficult for them uh to be an
effective political party so not up to
the job
uh no clear
coherent policy positions on anything
i mean literally on anything
and you've seen america's reputation on
the world stage
collapse
since afghanistan and we've just
discussed some of the knock-on effects
from that
and internally
well you've seen
a democrat party under biden
effectively take the knee
to a dangerous
marxist organization
intent on destroying
western democracy
and replacing it with something else and
that's called blm black lives matter and
we're all supposed to say oh what a love
i mean you know a really really really
bad organization
with massive spikes in lawlessness in
american cities i mean the likes of
which we simply can't believe
how can new york be going back to the
bad old days and when i first went there
back in the 80s and go out west
go out west and see what's happening in
many of those cities i mean you simply
can't believe it
so at every level
a democrat party that is there because
it's not donald trump a democrat party
that stands for almost nothing
and a democrat party was in big trouble
to crosstalk republicans
i mean donald trump's grip
on the republican party is very very
strong indeed
the
country club republicans
have been pretty marginalized you know
the mitt romneys the mitch mcconnell's
um the sort of rishi sunax if you like
of the republican party he'd be
marginalized and trump's in control
he's
75 but he's lost about 20 pounds since
the last election he's playing golf
pretty much every day
i've seen him a couple of times in the
last year he's in pretty good form
physically in pretty good form
clearly desantis
has done all the things that you would
approve of in florida in terms of not
allowing the state to take over too much
um clearly desantis is the up and coming
guy if trump wants the nomination it's
his
okay it's as simple as that
uh we're still some way off that
all i would say is this
my my my
my concern
having been at mar-a-lago
at the end of november
is that the people around trump
are
looking back too much
at november the 3rd
are talking constantly about the stolen
election
keep talking about the events
of the sixth of january
and it's really interesting
how do you win elections how do you win
referendums is it through negative
messaging
or is it through positive messaging and
there's a time and a place for both
but generally
i think to win elections
you've got to have a positive message
you have to see that churchill vision of
the sunlit uplands and that we're
heading off to a better place so i think
the trump team need to need to get out
of this current gear
if they leave themselves stuck
in this looking back
full of regret
as opposed to we're going to make sure
america has the best
most valid electoral system in the
western world which is the way of
turning a negative
into a positive so that's my that's my
reservation right now in his head he's
running
but do not worry nigel that
because i'm not a fan of the democrats
i'm not certainly not a fan of blm
but i look at trump
and i think that he's too divisive a
figure to be a truly unifying force for
america which is what it needs right now
well biden's not unified them either
um and
these these divisions that we've talked
about in this in this chat this
values-based
this values-based
we're morally superior to yours none of
this is going to be sold easily
none of this is going to be sold quickly
and as the
universities which have become the sort
of madrassas for marxism
churn out thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of more young
people every year with that mindset none
of this is going away in a hurry i do
get the fact that trump can be very
divisive i do get the fact that trump is
a you know a real fighting
puncher
um
and as with all political leaders as
with all human beings
you know you've got to see the good side
and the less good side and the less good
side is perhaps that aggression
you know i'd like to see him more in
public as he is in private
i'd like to see more of that sort of
lighter more humorous side yet we never
ever do
but
i do think
trump's period entire in office
i think his foreign policy uh was far
better than anything we've seen from
american presidents for a very very long
time
uh i i saw the other week
the um
the head of saudi arabia and israel meet
together in riyadh there was the israeli
flag the israeli national anthem i mean
unthinkable
and that was a direct result
of the abraham accords
had that been done by obama or anybody
else
they'd been up for a nobel peace prize
because it's trump it's been ignored you
know when trump called out the virus as
having leaked from the wuhan lab the
whole world ignored it because he'd said
it so yeah he is provocative he can be
very divisive i guess all of that
but i think his instincts on the really
big important things that face the world
right now are the right ones nigel if
you get a call in the middle of the
night and donald trump is having a bit
of a crisis of confidence about whether
he should run or maybe hand it off to
like a desantis or or someone dan
crenshaw there's there's really strong
candidates actually in my opinion on the
republican side
what would you say to him
i
do you anoint a successor i may have had
that conversation with him already but i
can't remember
well what might you have
you see i have met desantis
and he's really impressive
and i think the job he's done in florida
is phenomenal agreed because last may i
was in florida and i was in california
so i saw two countries both big
populations similar climates different
approaches and very different outcomes
you know economically socially and
everything else
to win the american election
you've got to win
every state
from the atlantic coast of pennsylvania
through the great lakes to wisconsin
they're the states that matter
they're the states that determine who
wins and loses the american presidential
election
and they're the states where you've got
the mining areas
they're the states where you've got the
heavy manufacturing areas
they're the states with their bits of
rust belt
and some bits of renewal
and they're states with a huge number of
democrat voters in them
but what's interesting in the polling is
that roughly 50 of democrats do not like
the leftward social drift do not like
the aoc staff are very uncomfortable
with some of the new trans gender stuff
that's being endlessly talked about um
hate the fact
that there are
democrats condemning american history
tearing down statues of the founding
fathers
telling them they should be ashamed to
be american they're proud to be american
they're proud of what their grandma and
grandad did in world war ii they're
proud at whatever stage their country
have come and adopted it you know
they're proud of being part of it
and so it's how do you get
a larger number of that group of people
to sort of cross over rather like the
red wall to cross over and vote
republican and who is the most likely
person
to appeal to those people i still
believe it's donald trump that i may say
different to you in two years time i may
say different to you you know as as
things really start to get ready
um and i guess really it's going to be
it'll be this time next year won't it be
it'd be one year's time it'll be early
23 when the big decisions about who's
going to run
who's going to put themselves forward
get made and why do you say that nigel
why is he more able to win those people
over there he's got the common touch
he's got the common touch you know he
speaks
a language they understand
they feel a certain familiarity with him
i've watched him
at these rallies
you guys see the bit in front of the
camera i've watched him with the crowds
i've watched him walk through the crowds
i've watched him
interact with people they love him
there's a certain humanity about him
there's something real about him
but also he's been part of their lives
for decades
you know big tv star
i mean
been in the news for decades with new
york and and and the real estate
successes and failures
they they feel they know the guy
now desantis who's incredibly bright and
impressive
you know can desantis reach those people
reach that community or is he just a
rich guy from florida
do you see what i mean yeah yeah you
know trump is like a blue-collar
billionaire you know
it's it's fascinating to watch it now as
i say in a year's time ask me again i
might have changed my mind but at the
moment that's what i believe
do you think the events of january the
6th
you look back at it and do you not think
that
heavily tarnished his reputation i was
awful
i was absolutely dire
i'm so so pleased i wasn't there
no i really am yeah and i
that would make a great photo and i
would just use smashing through the
gates
[Laughter]
i thought the whole thing was a mistake
i thought the whole thing was a mistake
uh i didn't
obviously anticipate exactly what would
happen
um was it a full-scale coup attempt no
of course not no i mean that's just
normal but this isn't about do you know
all of us but look it was it was
terrible um yeah yeah just just a
mistake from start to finish a mistake
from start to finish and of course the
democrats are going to go through a
whole series of um show trials
as we go on from here to try and prove
that it was a cool attempt they won't
succeed
uh yeah it was a mistake and i
i mean look
it's the same with boris's dilemma at
the moment isn't it
you know
it's carrie over influential on boris
you know has she led him in the wrong
direction yes
but ultimately boris is the boss
it's a bit the same with trump
i do feel
that some of the influences
that have that have been around him uh
in the white house uh perhaps weren't
all to the good
but i was pretty certain many of them
weren't all to the good but ultimately
he's the boss he takes the
responsibility so yeah january the sixth
not pretty but don't you think that if
he goes for election again
the people it's it's an easy thing to
pin on him
you know if you're a democrat i mean
that that's an easy hit yes look there's
no doubt about it
yeah there are no votes to be gained on
january the 6th
you know
no yeah it is one of those things that
detracts of course
nigel it's been really great to have you
back on the show uh always entertaining
always a pleasure and some very
interesting insights and by the way one
of the things we talked about before we
started is how rare it is for people
with different political views people
who disagree strongly about things to be
able to just have a normal conversation
so refreshing too
well thank you and i i have to say
that's what we have to get back to
we have to get back to passionate
but civilized discourse
and respecting the fact that different
people have different opinions and with
that we've got one final question for
you which is of course as always what is
the one thing that we're not talking
about that we really should be the class
divide
never gets discussed
you know we talk about divisions in
society
we talk about you know
ethnicity constantly are we being fair
to this group of people
or that group of people
far too little discussion on social
mobility
um and actually
what i see
is the more governments tax and
redistribute
the lower levels of social mobility are
for social mobility people need
opportunity they need that through
education which i mentioned earlier i
think is one of one of the great
challenges
ahead of us
uh they need it in the workplace uh and
working from home is not good for young
people
to get on
and so yeah i do think i do think that
uh it's good to see actually some 2019
red bull tory mps who come from working
working-class backgrounds uh but i do
think the class divide in this country
is set in stone
far more than it ever was the
opportunities to break out of it aren't
there you know world wars ironically
gave people from humble backgrounds a
chance
to move up through the ladder grammar
schools
for example gave a lot of people from
those backgrounds the chance to excel
and go up the ladder and i do ever so
slightly feel that middle class britain
has pulled the drawbridge up
well we're going to ask you a couple of
questions from our supporters in a
second but thank you so much for coming
back on the show and thank you for
watching and listening we'll see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or raw show all of them go
out 7 p.m uk time and for those of you
who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
on the really big broad historical
context uh yeah we're witnessing the end
of empire aren't we
you